wikipedia should you trust them
how many of us go and look at wikipedia
you know let me see the wikipedia for
whatever it may be
so the founder of wikipedia said nobody
should trust
wikipedia says founder larry singer
says site has been taken over by
left-wing
volunteers who writes off sources that
don't fit their agenda as fake
news wikipedia can no longer be trusted
as source of unbiased information side
the online encyclopedia left-leaning
volunteers can cut
out any news that doesn't fit their
agenda according to the founder larry
single co-founder wikipedia in 2001
alongside with jimmy wells
said the crowdsourcing project has
betrayed its original mission by
reflecting the views of the
establishment he said
he agreed with the assessment that the
team of democratic leaning voters
volunteers remove content that isn't to
their liking including information about
scandals
linked to joe biden and his son hunter
when asked if wikipedia can be trusted
he replied
you can trust it to give a reliably
establishment point of view on pretty
much
everything okay that's that's his
comment how many guys actually use
wikipedia actually
i do i do yeah i use i i use wikipedia i
think it's a uh uh
you know decent place to go to you know
see what they have to say i don't know
about how much of the stuff they take
off but i think a lot of people but i
don't use it for any
political reason i just look i look at
it for who was so-and-so
it's kind of like live mission or
they're running like pr for certain
people and certain things and it is
constantly updated you can throw snopes
in the same thing and that
you can throw the facebook fact checkers
in there it's all you know i
i get uh i get a strike against me on
facebook like
every every full moon so like two weeks
i get a strike against me on facebook
and then i go in
and i see which fact checker says that i
broke some sort of rule
and almost 100 of the time it's somebody
that
doesn't exist in real life they they
have they they come from beijing
mostly and that you can follow them you
you click in you gotta
you gotta have no time on your hands
like i do and you go in and you click
and you say okay who who did this they
show you who it is and then you look at
the articles that they've written and
everything like that and it's
it's it's like it's straight out of the
ccp
straight out of it it's straight
propaganda so well i have a question on
this wikipedia because this is the first
thing that came to mind
left leaning volunteers that's what the
article says right
so they're not paying people oh no the
volunteers writers
are volunteers all volunteers 100 so if
you're concerned that it's too
left-leaning
get some right-leaning volunteers
there's a system for it but but
you know there's a system is there a
tummy yeah there's a system for
who has enough scoring to be able to
write
and you know typically people who are
unemployed have more time to write
is this going to make you distrust going
on wikipedia like i'm still going to
like
let me ask you a question do you have
time to work for wikipedia and write
yourself of course now do you have time
to go up there and help them
out all the time gerard how are you
doing man you're going to go help them
write stuff up man i'm
i'm here to fight the culture or after i
get off of work with you at 11. i'll go
right typically whoever has the most
time
can ride a lot but you know it is scary
though it is scary to think about a
resource that
a lot of us use and depend on could be
slanted like that or or
whereas where it's revisionist where
they will remove or edit things just
but isn't that history in a nutshell yes
so whoever wins
the war this is the news right this is
the new religion adam i'm telling you
that just like
not new though is my point no no this is
this like leftist religion that
this is taking over the judeo-christian
perspective that we all grew up in
but you're right it's not not new but it
is much more
um able to be reached by everyone so
quickly you know it can have much more
of a dramatic and immediate impact so
it's much more powerful than it used to
be because
you know bridges can on their phone or
whatever and seconds go there but this
circles back to what pat said before
it's one thing to put that
there and that's fine you have your
perspective no problem
the problem becomes when you start
silencing or suppressing
or banning any counter perspective
that's the issue that's the hard line in
the sand
that's this whole like we talked about
oftentimes well it's both sides it's
both sides
yes it is to a degree except in
application
right because right now if you have a
counter perspective to the
the establishment they will silence you
they will digitally throw you in a gulag
they will take your page down
they will they will suppress your views
they will shadow ban you
they will do everything they possibly
can to limit your ability to expose your
perspective to the masses
while amplifying the perspective that
that they want to promote
so if you enjoy this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye